in terms of directing same thing is
there a certain formula that you advise
your directors or
it varies every time formula formula for
directing
you know there's a jungian theory
there's freudian there's all these
different things
so everyone has their own take on things
i would
i don't know but now you got me thinking
about it maybe there is
um there is
in a way i mean in one of my books i
have what's called the nine basic
steps and i think probably within that
there is sort of a formula
the nine basic steps are nine questions
the first question which we talked about
earlier is what is the story really all
about
in the first first four five six six
questions all have to do with the script
do you understand the script do you
understand the story do you understand
the characters and this
this is all leading up to directing so
my formula you know or approach is like
you've got to understand
script and story so deeply this is long
before you
and understand characters deeply list as
long before you start working
with actors because too many directors
will read a script and say okay let's
get some actors in here start working
and they
not only don't understand the script and
the characters
they haven't really sat down and done
the work they need to do on the script
to understand how it works or the need
getting back to the collaboration
that they should do the work they should
do with the writer
in other words going back to the writer
and asking the writer
i think one of the most important
questions you're going to ask a writer
you read the script who was it it was
i think it was harold clermon said you
know always start out with praise
great script great story you know just
keep everybody
happy and start with enthusiasm that's
what he said but to ask the writer
okay what compelled you to write this
which very few directors ask directors
to come in with a script and say
okay here's a problem we got an act you
know and they start attacking
the script i say don't attack the script
talk about the story in fact don't even
talk about the story talk about the
impulse for the story
and sometimes when you i mean i had a
script that i was working on that i was
going to direct which was a really harsh
brutal script about tough love and
deaths and killing
and i said to the writer why what
compelled you to write this
he says well i read about a case about a
young man who was
accused of killing a woman and
he said well i didn't murder her
it was tough love it was out of love
that she died
and he was convicted of murdering her
because actually he did kill her
but the writer said how could that
happen
how could a young man get to the point
in a relationship that thinks that
in a moment of passion and love and his
partner dies that he didn't really kill
her
and he wrote a he wrote a script
exploring that question i went wow
that's great now
and it was a great script but then at
that point i said okay now i understand
where the writer is coming from so in
terms of a formula get back to the
script get back to the story get back to
the writer and understand where they're
coming from then
move deeper into it so by the time
you're bringing in the actors
now you understand the material really
well
and we nothing we could talk about and
the writer's still there that's the
other thing we can talk about
but my sort of formula says
the last one of the last things you do
in making this film
is bring out a camera
i have these nine steps the first seven
we haven't even talked about cameras yet
and they said well i'm a filmmaker i
said i know but unless you understand
the story understand the script you know
how to work with actors you know how to
create
performances authentic performances you
know how to stage a scene you know how
to see
get a scene up on its feet in a
three-dimensional environment not on st
not on stage in a room or whatever
and make it work authentically then
maybe then you can start thinking about
a camera so that my these nine steps
take you on a sequence through it
to keep you honest and to keep you
focused on the story
not on filmmaking and this is a problem
with a lot of film schools where i teach
all over the world is the first thing
they do is they give them cameras
i said don't don't give me a camera and
when i teach like in munich i teach at
film school in munich and i go in and i
said okay the first thing we're
going to do is do you know how to tell a
story they all have their little scripts
i have a script i said yeah tell me a
story just tell me a story
can you even tell a joke if you could
tell a joke well
we're off to a good start and i say are
you a storyteller you're going to be a
filmmaker you should be a storyteller so
it's
all about what comes first and again
sort of like we were talking about you
know the passion for filmmaking and i
want to make films and i want to be and
i want to make
meet all these famous people you know
that's the wrong reason to make films
another wrong reason is make films as i
want to play with cameras and i want to
do editing
that's in fact cameras and editing all
the technology stuff is just
tools that we use in a delivery system
if the event we've created the scene or
this whole story
is not interesting then it's not worth
filming
so all of that has to come first so
there is so i do have sort of a
a sequence it's not really a formula
it's more of a sequence